today we're going to talk about one of
my favorite topics in computer science
which is the lambda calculus and in
particular we're going to talk about
three things we're going to think what
actually is it why is it useful and
where did it actually come from so we're
going to start with the last question
here where did it actually come from
this is Alonzo Church who was a
mathematician at Princeton University in
the United States and he was the person
who invented the lambda calculus and
what he was interested in is what is the
notion of a function from a
computational perspective and his answer
to this question is what we now know as
the lambda calculus and as an
interesting piece of history here which
many people don't know so it turns out
that Alonzo Church was the PhD
supervisor of someone very famous in
computer science Alan Turing and of
course Alan Turing amongst many other
things which he did he invented Turing
machines which computerphile has done a
number of videos on and Turing machines
capture a basic state based model of
computation and it's interesting that
his PhD supervisor Alonzo Church he
captured a basic functional notion of
computation with his lambda calculus and
it turns out that these two quite
different notions one functional and one
state-based turned out to be equivalent
and this is what's called the church
cheering hypothesis or part of the
church during hypothesis
so for Church a function was a black box
that you're not allowed to look inside
and what it does is it takes some input
so maybe it takes a number like X and
it's going to process it in some way and
it's going to produce an output so maybe
it produces the output X plus 1 so this
would be a function that takes a single
input a number called X processes it in
some way and then produces a single
output which is the number X plus 1 then
we could have a slightly more
interesting example maybe we have a box
with two inputs X and Y and we process
them in some way then maybe we produce
their sum as the output so this would be
a function which takes two and
X&Y processes them in some way and then
produces there some X plus y and there's
two important things about functions in
this sense the first is that their black
boxes you're not allowed to look inside
them you can't see the mechanics of
what's going on inside this box all you
can do is put something in and observe
what comes out at the other side and the
second important thing is that these
functions are pure they have no internal
state so all that happens when you map X
across to X plus one is the magic goes
on inside the box and there's no
internal state there's no hidden
information that we can use and this is
quite different from the notion of
computation that our ensuring was
interested in with his Turing machines
he had internal state there's no
internal state these are pure
mathematical functions now we can think
how do you actually define functions in
the lambda calculus and there's a very
very simple syntax for this which are
introduced you know so let's think about
the increment function in the lambda
calculus what you do is you write down
along the symbol so this is the Greek
lowercase letter lambda and that says
we're introducing a function at this
point and then you just write down the
name of the input so that was X and then
you have a dot and then you say how the
output is calculated in terms of the
input so that's X plus 1 so we could do
the same with addition you just need two
lambdas you're right lambda X dot lambda
Y dot X plus y so this is the function
that takes two inputs x and y and then
delivers the result X plus y and this is
written down formally in churches lambda
calculus exactly like this so when
you've got a function what can you do
with it well all you can do is give it
some input let it do its thing and it
will give you some output so let's have
a simple example of this if we take a
function like increment which was lambda
X X plus 1 and we apply it to a number
like 5 what actually happens it's a
basic process of substitution we're
essentially substituting the number 5
here into the body of this lambda
expression and then X becomes 5 so we
get 5 plus 1 and then we get the result
6 on the other side and this is
basically all there is to the lambda
calculus it's only got three things
it's got variables like X
Y and Zed it's got a way of building
functions this lambda notation and it's
got a way of applying functions this is
the only three things that you have in
this setting what is actually the point
of the lambda calculus we've introduced
this very simple notation why should you
be interested in learning about it I
think there's three answers which I
would give to this the first point I'd
make is that the lambda calculus can
encode any computation if you write our
program in any programming language
which has ever been invented or ever
will be invented or really any
sequential programming language it can
in some way be encoded in the lambda
calculus and of course it may be
extremely inefficient when you do that
but that's not the point this is a basic
idea of computation and we want to think
how many what kind of programs can we
encode in this and actually you can
encode anything and this is really the
kind of church cheering hypothesis which
I mentioned Alan Turing you can code
anything in his Turing machines and in
church's lambda calculus she could
encode anything and actually these two
systems are formally equivalent any
turing machine program can be translated
into equivalent lambda calculus program
and vice versa there are they're
formally equivalent the second point I
would make is that some calculus can
also be regarded as the basis for
functional programming languages like
Haskell so these are becoming
increasingly popular these days and
actually a very sophisticated language
like Haskell is compiled down to a very
small core language which is essentially
a glorified form of lambda calculus so
if you're interested in functional
programming like Haskell or the ML
family these are all fundamentally based
on the lambda calculus it's just kind of
a glorified syntax on top of that the
third point which I would make is that
the lambda calculus is actually no
present in most major programming
languages so this wasn't the case ten or
fifteen years ago but it is the case
today so if you look at languages like
Java like C sharp even Visual Basic F
sharp and so on all of these languages
no encode lambda calculus or include
lambda calculus as a fundamental
component so every computer scientist
today needs to know about lambda
calculus what I'd like to end up with is
a couple of little examples of what you
can do with it so the lambda calculus
has basically got nothing in it it's got
variables it's got a way of building
functions and
got a way of applying functions it
doesn't have any built-in data types
like numbers or logical values recursion
and things like that so if you want to
do these things in the lambda calculus
you need to encode them so I'll end up
showing you a simple encoding and the
encoding which I'm going to show you is
the logical values true and false and
the key to this is to think what do you
do with logical values in a programming
language and the basic observation is
that you use them to make a choice
between doing two things you say if
something is true do one thing if
something is false do another thing and
we're going to use this idea of making a
choice between two things to actually
encode true and false so the trick is
for true you write down this lambda
expression so what it does is it takes
two things x and y and then it chooses
the first and false does the opposite
it's going to take two things and it's
going to choose the second so we've got
two lambda expressions here both of
which take two inputs x and y and one
chooses the first one x and one chooses
the second one y so fair enough what can
we actually do with this well let's
think how we could define a little
logical operator so not is the most
simple logical operator which I can
think of it's going to flip true to
false and false to true it's logical
negation based upon this encoding how
could I actually define the not operator
or the not function well it's very easy
to do I will take in a logical value or
a boolean as it's normally called in
computer science after George Boole and
ooh first studied and a formal logic so
we take a boolean which will be one of
true or false and here's what we do we
apply it to false and we apply it true
and I claim that this is a valid
definition for a not function but I can
very easily convince you that it's the
case because I can do a little
calculation so let's check if we apply
not the true that we actually get false
and just a few steps using the lambda
calculus magic will find that this
actually works out so what can we do
here well the only thing we can do is
start to expand definitions so we know
what the definition of not is it was
lambda B V applied to false and true and
then we just copy down the true so all
I've done in the first step here is of X
funded my definition of not not was
defined to be this lambda calculus
expression here now I've got a function
which is this thing and it's applied to
an input so I can just apply it okay and
the function says if I take in a B I
just apply that B to false and true so
the thing I'm applying it to is true
here so I just do the little
substitution rather than be R right true
and then a copy down the false and copy
down the true and I get down to here and
at this point you might quite rightly be
thinking this looks like complete
rubbish we and I've just written true
false true what does that mean it means
absolutely nothing but it means
something in the lambda calculus because
we continue to expand so what we can do
now is expand the definition of true we
said that true takes two things and
chooses the first one so let's expand it
out so true is lambda X lambda Y X so it
chooses the first thing of two things
and then we just copy down the two
inputs false and true and you can see
what's going to happen now we've got a
function here which takes two things and
chooses the first thing here the first
thing is false so when we apply the
function we just get back false so what
you see has happened here in just a few
steps we've shown how using this
encoding of true and false and not we
can actually get the desired behavior
and it's very easy to check for yourself
if you apply not to false you get true
and I'd like to set set your little kind
of puzzle at this point think how you
could define logical and or logical or
in this style as well okay and I'm
interested to see what kind of
definitions people come up with in the
comments so the very last thing I'd like
to show you is this lambda expression
here which is a very famous lambda
calculus expression called the Y
Combinator or the Y operator and
actually this is the key to doing
recursion in the lambda calculus so as I
mentioned lambda calculus has basically
nothing in it or it's only got three
things in it variables x y&z and so on a
way of building functions and a way of
applying functions it's got no other
control structures no other data types
no anything so if you want to do
recursion like which is the basic
mechanism for defining things in terms
of themselves again computer files have
videos on this you need to encode it it
turns out that this expression here is
the key to encoding recursion
in the lambda calculus and this
expression was invented by someone
called Haskell curry and this is the
Haskell that gives his name to the
Haskell programming language and he was
a PhD student of David Hilbert who's a
very famous mathematician the last
observation I'd like to leave you with
here is something that's interested me
for many years I think is a connection
between this piece of kind of abstract
computer science or abstract mathematics
and biology if you look at human DNA you
have this double helix structure you
have two copies of the same thing side
by side and this is the key to allowing
DNA to self-replicate if you look at the
structure of this lambda expression here
you have two copies of the same thing
side by side you have lambda X F applied
to X X and exactly the same here and
this is the key to doing recursion which
is kind of related to self replication
in a programming language or in the
lambda calculus and for me I don't think
this is a coincidence I think it's a
kind of interesting philosophical
observation the lambda calculus has this
kind of very clever way of doing
recursion which would take a video on
its own to explain how it actually works
but you can look it up on Wikipedia and
there's a link here I think to biology
somebody actually found the Y Combinator
so interesting that they've had it
tattooed permanently on their arm and
you can find the picture of this if we
do a quick web search what would people
search for the Y called the Y Combinator
in mathematics or computer science and
tatsuya I'm guessing yep